all right let's do
let's do this game and let's play
blindfold okay good luck
okay uh got a nice italian game here
on knight f6
i tried this once and realized my rating
is way too low for this
it's tough
it's tough okay we get d3
there's not a move i'm super excited to
see because these games are very often
very positional which is going to
[Music]
i think it's going to be harder for
normal
harder than normal for me
when i'm playing blindfolded
uh but you know we'll see how we do play
bishop c5
lok vindi okay he plays knight c3 which
some move i'm happy to see
because
the main theory plan states to play c3
and d4 so we should be pretty good here
uh a6
um
we'll go a6 yeah
i don't want to play d6 because if i
play d6 then knight a4
picks up the bishop pair and i don't
think i like that
is it hot in here
bishop e3
okay
i don't need to take i'm not going to
back up either
could play knight d4 it's not a bad move
bishop g4
bishop g4 looks pretty good
g4
oh
oh i didn't play d6 yet
okay well i guess we'll play d6
um
i guess we'll start with d6 in that case
i thought i already played d6 okay this
is gonna be a good game i can already
tell
i can already tell this is going to be a
good game
um
did i bring water for the clock too i
did not
i'm sorry
i need to i need to apologize to the
clock after the game
what is my point 1600 1684 looks like i
intentionally chose
um
a lower rated opponent
for this game because of course it's
it's going to be more difficult for me
okay um yeah i think we just castle here
it's a pretty standard play
destroy them so badly that they cry for
the next decade
a decade's a long time though
decade is good enough
to go from 1600 to
much better than 21.82
so
um yeah
you could you could spend that time
doing something much more useful
than crying
although that's not to say that crying
is
a completely useless activity
it can be a
very nice
cathartic
coping mechanism so
yeah crying is good
i like crying but only when i'm by
myself
because otherwise it's embarrassing if
you're crying in front of other people
that can be can be embarrassing
uh well
h6 it's a pretty standard play here i
think h6
just kicking the knight away
and the knight can't come to f3 anymore
so
uh very yeah very very standard it's
gonna have to go to h6
and then i think we've even got some
tactics here
okay well the knight takes on h on f7
um
which of course is going to be good for
us
positionally
although it's probably his best play
anyway
to sack the knight
or the rook and
second knight in bishop for the rook and
pawn
water
water kills clocks
wait he takes immediately as well which
i think it was maybe possible for him to
keep this pin for a little while longer
but um i mean yeah either way
uh you know
it's not going to matter too much we're
still going to have the advantage here
with two pieces for
the rook
c7 is defended you played knight d4 here
knight d4 the queen's gonna have to come
back to d1 in order to guard c2 still
equal material though
uh yo bye bear what's up man nice to
have you again great to have you here
great to have you here
oh bishop takes d4
um i kind of forgot about that bishop on
e3 but that's okay because
we take with the pawn or the
bishop probably the
bishop i think
um okay where are the pieces so
i've got a bishop midnight he's got a
knight and a queen
and i've got a bishop on c8 the queen
pawns
and
this should be where all the pieces are
right
like that
that's where all the pieces are oh no
that that pawn is on a6
that looks right
all right so i'm expecting c3 next we'll
probably play bishop g4 right i guess so
yeah i guess we'll
trade queens the less pieces for me to
keep track of
it's going to be good the bishop pair
should out play the rooks
or the extra rook so
um overall our opponent has just handed
us a winning position
especially if they trade queens
then it's just a matter of converting
which hopefully shouldn't be too
difficult now the question is do i take
with the pawn or the king
that's actually close
i wonder i wonder if i could see the
whole board if if my decision would be
like really easy or if i still would be
unsure i think taking with the pawn
because i think i want to play f5
a little bit later then it'll be good
obviously he has to play c3
to
save the b2 pawn
we just drop back to b6 it's no problem
so yeah this should be pretty good
king e8 is obviously the best move queen
takes f6 king e8
classic
obviously the best move
okay he goes for f3
which is interesting
[Music]
i think it's probably a mistake though
it just gives my bishop such a nice
diagonal and
um the d3 pawn is probably going to be
weak a little bit later
especially set because we said we were
going to play f5 right
so let's do it let's go for f5
he can't really play d4
maybe
maybe this was maybe slightly inaccurate
i guess he's probably going to be able
to get d-file pressure with his rook so
he castles
but now
we
can i guess if we play d4
he has he got he has d4 himself
so
let's start with bishop e3
and then we'll go for d4 is that what is
that what we want to do check
could go for c5 here just to clamp on d4
that actually looks like a fantastic
move we'll play c5
perfect c5 i love it takes we'll just
take and that's going to be check yeah
mostly the main plan here is we're just
stopping d4
just for h4
i don't think that
really does anything
uh we play f4 yeah i think we do we'll
make the g pawn backwards
and we're gonna get very nice rook
pressure on this g-file we've got the
pawns
all in a row like this
and he plays rook d e one but i don't
think that's a big
concern does this
does this bishop placement matter
probably bishop e6
the best
but it's hard to say
a bishop e6 then we just want to play
rook g8
could continue storming the queen side
here as well
it goes for g3
but we do now have bishop f2 which
should just be omega winning
yo the klansman what's up man klansmen
70. yo thank you very much for the raid
with the nine people
i know it's it might not seem like a lot
but nine people that's a lot that's a
lot of people that's like
as many people as
were in my college writing class
so
i mean i mean that's like a whole class
of people that's a lot
uh yo but thank you for the raid we're
just doing some nice old classic
blindfold chest right now
uh you know i mean you know the deal
classic blindfold chess just a regular
old tuesday
um
now the question here is you take with
the pawn or the bishop
and i think you take with the
pawn
you take the pawn
looks good and we are actually threading
the immediate
g2 i believe
yeah because there's a pawn on f3
so rook takes f2 is not going to be
check
so we are threatening g2 immediately
even one person is amazing
greetings from germany um
uh
uh
guten
good not ugh good knock had germany
uh uh good knockout joyce deutschland
perfect
um
thank you to german thank you what's up
to the german
guten albin
i don't know what that means oh no
one plays a3 and immediately proposes a
take back okay i'll i'll give you the
benefit of a doubt and say that that was
a mouse slip
good knocked okay
god got it
i don't know a lot of german
that's
that's basically as much german as i
know
and and like like i know like a little
bit of ramstein you know
ramstein ramstein
ramstein which one is it
ramstein though i mean ramstein has got
the bangers
i i mean
radio
deutschland both
massive massive bangers
so yes big time the big time pog on
uh rhyme stein
ramstein
okay i don't think rook d1 does
a lot
so i'm just going to play rook g8 i
think that's good
good night clams clan uh klansmen have a
good
great night
done a lot of blunderings tonight yeah
go to bed
nice band
i'll check the pronunciation right now
ram
how do you pronounce this
we are looking at how to pronounce the
name of this german musical band we'll
be looking at how to say more
interesting and often mispronounced
names from music
and also more names from german
that are confusing so make sure to stay
tuned for those
how do you say it
in german it is said as hamstein
ramstein so an emphasis on the first
syllable
and it's not
stein
yes i know it's an s t but it's
pronounced like
cht rather
hammerstein so it'd be fine in english
to say perhaps
ramstein ramstein but not ramstein
ramstein in german and now all right
we're just gonna go with ramstein
that was a i don't know did you guys
were you guys able to hear that video
okay uh so
we're up a queen my opponent has no
pieces left
but i can't remember where all the pawns
are i think there's a pawn in c3
um we're just gonna go check we're gonna
play queen f3 next
because
i think there's a pawn on f3 so let's
just get rid of that one
or if my opponent goes to the back rank
that that would be perfect
that's that's of course the most ideal
situation because then we can just
um we can just clean things up
i think
without too much problem without too
much trouble
king c1
okay i think i can pick up the a2 pawn
here
so yeah let's do that we'll play bishop
takes a2 and then
probably back to b3
and should be mate in a couple more
moves
why i only have 2k
oh you weren't able to hear it
oh
um
it was like a
one minute video on how to pronounce
uh
the uh how to pronounce ramstein
ramstein
uh all right cool all right good game
good game lok vindi
yeah i think this is a pretty
standard game i mean i think my opponent
made
a pretty egregious
positional blunder in the beginning
which was this this knight g5 combined
with queen f3 combined with knight f7 i
think queen f3 was probably the mistake
because now after h6
uh the knight has to come back to h3
and then um
[Music]
well i was thinking that there was this
knight e4 move
and that this probably wasn't very good
for
white because
white moves the queen back to defend c2
then they get their shattered but this
is probably not super bad for white to
be honest so
maybe queen f3 is not a super bad move
but knight takes f7 is definitely
not what you want to be playing
because even though the rook and the
pawn and the two minor pieces even
though they're both worth six points
um the minor pieces can coordinate
together much much better than the rook
and the pawn especially in the early
game and middle game so
um it
just leads to
um
a big disadvantage
it's it's almost never going to be worth
it
you can see the computer
completely agrees
i already have a massive advantage after
king takes f7 if a rook takes f7 uh and
yeah my opponent just made it very easy
they traded everything
and
then
we
we stopped this d4 breakthrough that was
i think the next big thing
um
although that was our job to do
really at that point that was just
conversion technique
um
[Music]
and then after we stop this breakthrough
the next main thing is
fixing this as a backwards pawn so now
we have a now we have a big target to go
after which is the g2
and then the final blow was just this
tactical mistake of
g3 which just falls into the fork
unfortunately
um
and
yeah my opponent they sacrifice i think
they basically just gave up after this
i couldn't really remember where all the
pawns were at the end because i was
focused i was focused on
uh other things like uh i was just
chatting with chat and stuff i figured
the position was was very winning
um
and i was up a queen so i'm like okay
now that i'm up a queen i can kind of
forget about the pawns
um but i did remember that uh there were
pawns like this so i figured okay i'll
take here and then i'll come back to b2
i didn't remember where the d3 pawn was
though i can remember if it was on d3 or
d4
um
although if i had thought about it for
like two seconds i would have realized
it was on d3 because
we prevented this d4 right that was the
whole point of c5
and yeah just to mate in a couple more
moves so yeah lock vin d very good game
to you my friend very good game